NARRATOR: Going into the 1920s
many people
believed banning alcohol would
make America more peaceful.
They were wrong.
Violent murders,
widespread corruption,
and the dawn of organized crime
defined the decade and beyond.
In the years leading
up to the 1920s,
antialcohol activists,
such as Carrie Nation,
had been hard at work building
a case against the demon drink,
and they had some
legitimate arguments.
Prohibitionist women
advocated for temperance
as a means of combating their
abusive alcoholic husbands.
Industrialists got
behind the movement
because they thought alcohol was
limiting the potential output
of their average worker.
But temperance was also
used by racist organizations
as an outlet for
their xenophobic views
against the millions
of European immigrants
coming to the United States.
The Germans and
Irish in particular
were scorned for their
alleged drunkenness.
Whatever their reasons,
46 states ultimately
ratified the 18th Amendment
with only Connecticut
and Rhode Island dissenting.
Prohibition
officially took effect
at the very start of the
decade, enforced by the language
of the Volstead Act,
named for House Judiciary
chairman Andrew Volstead.
Within a year, Americans'
alcohol consumption
had already dropped
to historic lows,
but the drop was temporary.
Americans didn't stop drinking.
The 18th Amendment allowed
for some loopholes--
fermenting grapes at home,
prescriptions from doctors,
and religious exemptions.
A lot of people found God.
But the eradication of a
corporate structure for alcohol
production and distribution
left a huge opportunity
for a large-scale,
organized, and insanely
profitable black market.
Existing small-time
street gangs took
advantage, quickly evolving
into vast bootlegging
criminal enterprises.
They employed everyone from
warehouse workers to truck
drivers to accountants.
Gang leaders would
bribe politicians, cops,
even the Prohibition agents
themselves, nicknamed Prohis,
to ensure their
businesses ran smoothly.
Some relied on rum running,
illegally importing liquor
from other countries and storing
it in warehouses across the US.
Sometimes they
would simply distill
liquor in private homes.
Other gangsters bought
abandoned breweries
and operated them in secret.
They worked in the shadows,
but one part of the business
was very public, the violence.
Gangs fought for territory in
the streets of major US cities.
Chicago was especially violent.
729 people were killed
by gangs in Cook County
alone during Prohibition.
The most famous
of these incidents
was the St. Valentine's
Day massacre in 1929.
Men working for Al Capone,
dressed as policemen,
gunned down seven rival members
of Bugs Moran's gang against
the wall of a parking garage.
No one was ever
charged for the crime.
Realizing cooperation could
lead to greater profits,
many gangs agreed
to treaties that
allowed them to
operate peacefully
in their respective territories.
Johnny Torrio attempted to
organize the gangs in Chicago
with Al Capone as
his right-hand man.
When Torrio retired to
Italy and handed the reins
to his protege, Capone
inherited a business
pulling in more than $1 billion
a year in today's terms.
Charles "Lucky"
Luciano organized
the Italian and Jewish
gangs in New York
under Joe "The Boss" Masseria
before Luciano had Masseria
killed in 1931 and had his
successor, Salvatore Maranzano,
killed the same year.
Luciano went on to found The
Commission, a national crime
syndicate composed of New
York's five mafia families
and the controlling families
in Chicago and Buffalo.
Prohibition ended
with the ratification
of the 21st Amendment
in 1933, but the mafia
kept rolling along.
These crime families had
already entered the worlds
of loan sharking, prostitution,
and illegal gambling,
just to name a
few, and continued
to grow throughout the country
on the backs of their profits
from Prohibition.
INTERVIEWER: You must have
in your mind something
you've done that you can
speak of to your credit
as an American citizen.
If so, what are they?
Paid my tax.
[laughter]